je suis perdu dans la
tempête affollé par les
vaguelettes mais grâce à mon
tempérament je lutte contre les
éléments
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
je suis le naufragé
entre les
cocotiers ohé
ohé sur une île
déserte mon bateau a échoué oh
oh bien je suis sur l'île j'avais
essayer d'aller chercher à manger
maintenant
oh mais quange du bruit vite allons nous
cacher derrière ce palmier ah trop
[Applaudissements]
tard
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
Hai
[Musique]
Hoi
h Hawaï le
[Musique]
décor
hawï
C
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
à
l'étranger bonjour les amis je suis
[Musique]
l'étranger
c'est la première fois que je le vois
papa et j'ai déjà mon cœur qui
B quelle est ce B
étranger qui m'as toute retourner déjà
déjà amour Amour Amour
oleillé la vie est magique
aque la vie est fantastique amour amour
amour en
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
soleillé mais qui est cet étranger qui
va me ravir le cœur de ma promise il
faut que je m'en débarrasse qui de
en
[Musique]
chemise
B papa voyez là-bas cet
étranger on dit que leur chair
est il nous faut tout de suite le
mer
ça nous changera du
surgelé
surg les produit
aique la vie est magique
aqueour est
[Musique]
fantastique
dis-moi beendre oui tu as vraiment de
bonnes idées moi il en avoir pas
[Musique]
pensé cuisinier la nuit va
tomber mais la viande nous garde
manger nous ferons miam miam nous ferons
miam miam nous ferons miam miam
oh au petit
déjeuner je su le
cuisinier je vais te faire
grill je suis le
marmiton je vais te faire au petit
[Musique]
lardon la vie est magique a sur trque la
vie est fantastique mi
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
mi
[Musique]
tu nana tu nana tu n'as pas l'air dans
ton assiette demain tu demain tu demain
tu finiras dans la mienne comme tu comme
tu comme tu lui as tourné la tête je te
dis je te dis je te
divorerai
[Musique]
laen
tout
se dans la nuit
[Musique]
brune
ligoté comme un
gigot je
pleure S la
[Musique]
lune oh
malheur des S
[Musique]
gllu à
l'étranger je
[Musique]
suis j'ai
préparé une
Pirog c'est
là c'est
là c'est là c'est seu merci seu qui ne
soit pas
troué
pasoué
pasoué la vie est magique
atique la vie est fantastique
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
ouéoué mais où est passé le prisonnier
où est parti ma fiancé est par M
manger
je suis un père des laiss je vais sortir
mes
[Musique]
surgel je vais me
suicider
[Musique]
bouou la vie
est la vie est tique
pouryer en
[Musique]
oublieropique la vie est
magique tropique la vie est
[Musique]
fantastique